the patriots got to ten and one yeah
with a win over the cowboys and here's
my take on the cowboys especially owner
jerry jones
the closer they get to getting a
signature win
when they don't get it
it drives him nuts two weeks ago they
had a potential signature win against
the vikings on sunday night football
and then yesterday going to foxborough
horrible weather conditions 13 to 9 a
game they could have won it felt just
kind of like you thought it would
patriots would win but the cowboys would
keep it close and maybe they have a
chance to pull it out right and we gotta
we gotta hear and react to jerry jones
after the game because if i'm jason
garrett yeah no more green bananas right
right right start thinking about real
estate agents start thinking about next
destinations because he's got five games
left on his contract and he may not even
make it to week 17 based on how upset
jerry was after the game here's jerry
jones following the loss to new england
you had a sloppy day special teams can
rule today
and they've got a coach knows how to
play this game and did a good job of
that my hat's off to us i don't think
there's a game that a coaching staff
has areas that it wouldn't uh couldn't
do better in
and
i just
don't like it that we've got so many as
i'm standing here tonight
yeah i mean it's kind of a convoluted
comment that he made but the bottom line
is i'm sick of having these games where
the coaching lets us down he he said
more too let me let me amplify some of
things please special teams is a total
reflection of coaching right he said
that right and he also said with the
makeup of this team this team that that
i jerry jones built right i shouldn't be
this frustrated right hey listen he's
right i i'm sorry i'm a jason garrett
fan you know i am i really in a lot of
ways i hate to say hey would you say if
you weren't well yeah well but but the
the big thing is i mean jerry jones has
a point they he has built a team of
adonises
if we flipped that team over and just
said bill belichick you coach the
cowboys
and jason garrett you coached the new
england patriots the cowboys would blow
the new england patriots out they would
just go position for position offensive
line cowboys are better running back
ezekiel speller quarterback i'm sorry
dak prescott is better at this point of
his career than tom brady defensive line
you're going to take the cowboys
secondary you'll take the patriots but
it's not in a landslide because the
cowboys secondary is very good middle
linebackers both it's very close but you
know again that was a close one maybe
i'd give the edge to the patriots but
it's really really close they walk on
the field
not almost they walk on the field every
sunday as the better physical team the
day and age of this is what we do we're
gonna play simple and play hard it's
over get over it the new england
patriots play complex and hard what is
so bad about that you know that's what
you have to do the day and age of just
going this is what we do and we're not
going to mess up is that that has come
and gone it just hasn't game plan
specific game planning is the key to the
game in the nfl now and you see the
great teams do it whether it's the
ravens or the 49ers uh you know of
course the patriots
all those teams they all do it the
seattle seahawks changed their defensive
game plan when they played the 49ers a
few weeks ago you have to do that you
just can't think you're going to go
against some of the nfl elite and go
this is what we do and we'll win okay
jason garrett's a smart guy right he
went to princeton right most of the
people i know who went to princeton are
smart except for one except for one um
ross tucker i i'm just kidding uh but uh
right um
what's the issue why wouldn't he i don't
know well you know to me there's two
things you've heard me say about the
defense i've said it to them blue in the
face you can't just line up in two
defenses all games but but why i mean
that's but when it's so obvious yes that
game specific planning i know is the key
to winning in the attention today's nfl
what is it that is keeping that from
getting into jason's garrett's brain
and and and him accepting that
is it it can't be laziness these guys
all work hard yeah they do they're not
working smart right yeah i think so and
i think you know it takes a lot of work
though
to be creative and you know maybe that's
where it gets ends i don't want to say
the word lazy because no nfl coach is
lazy they're grinders they really are
but it's harder to be creative and then
come up with ooh is it creative and
sound behind it right i think the right
word is and i don't mean this in the
political way i think conservative is
the word right i think that might be the
way i have my way
right these are my ways this is what
works stay the course meat and potatoes
yes you get big strong guys and you're
gonna prevail right you're gonna win
some and you're gonna lose some but
you're gonna have a good team yes the
only problem is you're gonna have a team
that hasn't been in the nfc championship
since 1995 and probably isn't going to
get back this year because you're going
to come up against somebody who puts
together the game plan that that is able
to exploit your weaknesses that are
obvious because you don't change
anything definitely you know and again
even though you have the more talented
team on the nfl this day and age in the
nfl everything is so close come on we're
seeing you know you know damn pittsburgh
was lucky to squeak out with the worst
team in football yesterday against the
cincinnati bengals it doesn't matter who
you are the difference between the best
and the worst is not that great
even though the cowboys are clearly the
better team when they walk on the field
almost 99 of the time and that's where
it's troubling and he's right about the
special teams and everything that goes
with it case in point yeah would jason
garrett have the flexibility to yank his
quarterback if he needed to or would he
be thinking i don't want to deal with
all the issues they're going to come
after it you know i mean mike tomlin
knew the time had come to make this
overdue yeah make that move make that
move but that's that flexibility you
have to be willing to adapt on the fly
you cannot walk into a game with this
rigid inflexible mindset or you are
going to end up get and it's amazing
he's lasted as long as he has yeah with
that mindset yeah it really is it is
well you know there's some good things
to say what you said about conservative
but it's just not going to always get
you over the top and get you into the
cream of the crop in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports